according to sean serrania the rockets
and the thunder
are planning to boycott game five of
their series as well so
as promised a developing situation let's
head back down to orlando
hard working rebecca harlow what's the
latest you're hearing down there
yes well chris buck's general manager
john horst was very respectful in
addressing
the media now just so you know there
were only about a handful of us
back outside of the bucs locker room
waiting for any kind of word from the
team he let us know that there will be
an official statement
coming from the bucks organization but
that likely the players would remain
inside of the locker room for a while so
he told us
that we didn't necessarily need to wait
the players might not speak today they
might not even speak tomorrow
but again that there would be an
official statement coming from the bucks
but what i can tell you guys is this
being around here in the bubble i have
talked to
several bucks players who have told me
that as a team their initiative
is all about creating awareness around
voting
wesley matthews has been very vocal in
that he wears
vote on the back of his jersey some of
the things that they're looking to do at
fizzer
forum back at their home arena they want
to make that a voting site so there are
different initiatives that they really
want to do to create that real systemic
change but again an official statement
might not be coming today
now i've texted with several players
from other teams who tell me
they're also watching this unfolding and
that they're undecided
as to whether or not they'll be
boycotting their games as well
moving forward those players that you've
uh texted and spoken to have they said
that there's anything that they want in
particular as an
end result and do any of them have plans
on leaving orlando because that's a very
different situation
no i haven't heard anything like that
i've not been getting
the sense or the message from any
players that they're planning on leaving
orlando now that doesn't mean that they
might not make that decision
or make the decision to stay but right
now everything just feels very up in the
air but what i can
say is that the players feel very
strongly
about creating that systemic change it's
not just about wearing a t-shirt it's
not just about
you know pictures or shoes it's about
how to create
real change for americans so
that is the message that they're
continuing to try to get out here in
orlando
rebecca harlow thank you for your report
yet again
we appreciate you let's
uh head now to stephanie reddy who is
also
was scheduled to be on the sidelines for
tonight's okc
houston game according to multiple
reports
that game also planning to be boycotted
as well
stephanie can you confirm those reports
what is the latest
i have not hello chris i've not been
given any official word but i can just
tell you what i have witnessed because
as you mentioned i
am here in the building um at about 4 15
there were players on the court
shooting getting shots up warming up
coaches sitting on the bench as you know
is often uh the case when the coaches
are waiting for players to come out and
then this happened we see someone
leaving
the locker room from the thunder and we
can follow them you can see now the
gentleman in the gray shirt he comes
out and he appears to deliver a message
because you can see all the heads turn
and the blue jerseys the blue shirts
players and assistant coaches that are
helping those players get warmed up and
then they all
leave the court to go to the back nearly
around that same time
i also witnessed houston rockets
officials the staff
some of the coaches that were waiting
for players to come out they also went
into the back
of the um arena area where their locker
room is
now that was 4 15 and now here we are 30
minutes later and things have escalated
and progressed quite quickly shortly
after that we're going to show you some
film
where we saw russell westbrook and chris
paul
they were meeting in a room together
here they are leaving it was about 10
minutes
they were in that room now the reason
why this is important is not just
because they're leaders for their two
teams
but as you may know chris paul is the
president of
the nbpa so anything that happens as it
relates to the players union
he obviously is going to have a lot of
say in what's going on
shortly thereafter we did see
players leaving the building so as i've
mentioned i have not been
told anything official as it relates to
this game that was supposed to start at
6 30
but we will be showing you pictures
players leaving the building
now i have been texting with coaches and
players from other teams to see what
they know
and i've been told that they're united
they want change
i texted with someone with the orlando
magic because i was very curious
is this a decision the bucks made
unilaterally unilaterally excuse me
or was this a joint decision they made
with the orlando magic because we saw
both teams leaving the building going to
their buses i was told
absolutely they are all united they want
change that has been the united message
now remember when this all started the
talk of boycotting it was with the
boston celtics and the toronto raptors
they're supposed to play tomorrow they
were the first two teams that actually
broached this topic publicly
they already had a meeting together i
was told they are still planning on
meeting tonight
the two teams boston and toronto because
they still did not come to a final
decision
about what they wanted to do with their
game things have obviously changed quite
quickly
because now we have two games
potentially we have not received
official word about this one yet
but two games in the nba that are being
boycotted by the players
to make a united stand for the things
that they believe in the reason why they
said they were here not just to try to
win a championship but to also use their
platform
use their voices to initiate change so
chris it is very fluid here i'll do my
best to keep you up to date
stephanie first and foremost great job
you answered about five
follow-up questions with your reporting
so thank you for that but i just want
one clarification when you say the
players say that they
want change we understand that's not
with
their situation in orlando that's with
social justice is there a particular
thing
that they've said that they want when
they say we want change
you know i've i've heard many things
that they're looking to change
obviously you hear people talking a lot
about voting and how important that is
because that
is an exact change that you can make if
you can affect
policy then you can affect the change so
you hear players talking about voting
registration making sure they get as
many people out to the ballot box as
possible
but you also hear the talk about police
brutality and i think this latest
incident in kenosha wisconsin has
sparked that
again they say that it's unfortunate
they're using their voices they're
wearing the shirts it's printed on the
court that black lives matter
they don't feel like it's enough they
don't feel like
their voices are being heard strong
enough so this
is one more way that the players of the
national basketball association
are trying to affect change